JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello
and welcome to
YouTube Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
We will talk about getting a
deal on a movie ticket with
Dealflicks.
So let me introduce
our guests.
I have Zach and Steven
today in the studio.
How are doing guys?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Pretty good.
How are you?
STEVEN NGUYEN: Good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Doing good.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
I work in YouTube developer
relations.
And I understand you guys are
based out in San Francisco.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yep, we're
just in the Mission area.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Cool.
Well thank you for coming down
here to Mountain View.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Not a problem.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So tell us
a little bit more about
what you guys do.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, Dealflicks
is a Priceline for
movie tickets.
So essentially, you come to our
website dealflicks.com,
find a theater near you, find
the movies that are playing
there that we have, and find
a deal up to 60% off.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So how did you guys come
up with the idea?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, so Sean
really started this idea when
he was graduating
from Berkeley.
He was going to see "The King's
Speech." And it was a
pretty awesome movie, but it
was like 10 people in this
room of 400 seats.
So he's like, ahh there's
got be something to do--
it was economic background.
And he's like, we should be
able to do a Priceline fro
movie tickets.
And that's how Dealflicks
started.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
I heard that your founders
actually ended up seeping in a
van at some point in the
beginning of the company.
Its that true?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, it's
actually more recently they're
still kind of sleeping
in this van.
So Kevin and Evan--
our two founders, who want
do the theater sales.
So they go to these conventions
around the country
meet these theaters and
basically spend time around
there trying to mop up
all the different
videos we can for you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So this is what it takes
nowadays to start a company?
You've got to sleep
in your car?
ZACHARY CANCIO: I think so.
I think it's the new garage.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good one.
All right.
Well, so why don't you show
us a little demo.
How does your product work?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah
sounds good.
So you can go to our site
dealflicks.com.
You can check out a movie
in San Francisco.
We're going to look at "The
Internship." I heard this is
about a pretty cool company.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That is true.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACHARY CANCIO: Ah, so yeah.
We got Rotten Tomato
scores here.
We can show you a little blurb
about the movie, show you
different show times.
And the cool thing is you can
watch a trailer right
from the home page.
So here's a little "Internship"
preview.
Hopefully after this
point, you really
want to see the movie.
And you just click out, hit
the go button like I am.
And here you go.
You can see at this show
time, we have a deal
for $7.80, 25% off.
I want to see it tonight, so
I'll pick the 7:30 showing,
choose a couple tickets,
hit Buy Now.
And that's it.
I'm on the confirmation page.
I could put in a little
coupon code--
YouTube live.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, wow.
Is that a secret coupon code?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Just
for you guys.
Just for you guys.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACHARY CANCIO: $5 discount--
put in my credit card.
And that's it-- pretty much
good to go after that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So if you're watching live
right now, we can use the
coupon code.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
You can use it after this too.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So you guys have a
web application.
I understand you also
have a mobile app.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah yeah.
Steven here can demo you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Let's take a look.
STEVEN NGUYEN: So with our
Android app, we implemented
the sign with Google feature.
So I will go and sign in.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you're
signing in with Google+.
STEVEN NGUYEN: Yeah, sign
in with Google+.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So while Steven is setting it
up, so tell me a little more
about the Android app, like
what's the capabilities and
what you guys implemented.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, so it's
a completely native app.
We really try to streamline
the process.
So you just find your
theater, pick your
movie, pick your deals.
So we've integrated YouTube,
though, the YouTube native
player, so basically allow you
watch the trailer without
having to leave the app and
avoid having to come back and
find where you are too.
So that was really cool.
The SDK was really simple
to integrate.
And then pretty much
after that, it's--
I hope it's as easy
as it can be.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I see
Steven signed in successfully.
So should we switch to the
app and see what it does?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Sounds good.
STEVEN NGUYEN: Sounds good.
So from here, I can go to the
same movie that Zach just
showed you guys.
So I go to "The Internship," and
from here, we can look all
the information of the
movie and look at the
Rotten Tomato score.
And we can watch the trailer.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Pretty nice.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So this is using the YouTube
Android player API?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Exactly.
STEVEN NGUYEN: Yes.
STEVEN NGUYEN: So let
me pick a ticket.
And I can check out using the
same coupon code YouTube.
ZACHARY CANCIO: The
secret deal.
The secret deal is
just for today.
[LAUGHTER]
The password is--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Nice.
STEVEN NGUYEN: So here, after
that, I can just enter my
credit card number
and [INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Uh huh.
Great.
And then you get an email?
Or how you actually--
what do you do in the theater?
ZACHARY CANCIO: So at the
theater-- you'll get an email.
You can show that email
voucer to them.
It has a confirmation code.
And then you can also show
that on your device.
So within--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, I see.
ZACHARY CANCIO: You can go
back to your purchases.
I think you have a
couple purchases.
STEVEN NGUYEN: [INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Not
on this account.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Not
But yeah, you can just show your
purchase on your phone.
And then that's it.
The theater has a back-end
system where they
reconcile the deal.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Cool.
So tell me a little bit more
about your implementation,
maybe starting with your
web application.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah.
Yeah.
So we run--
we program in Python.
We're using the Tornado
framework.
It's just a really simple system
that I like, really
bare bones, allows me
to write the SQL
ourselves if we need to.
And that's it.
We created basic rest API that
all our apps talk to.
And that's what you've seen on
iOS and on the Android device.
And we have some hook-ins,
like Facebook--
or Google+ really is what we've
been focusing on lately.
So you saw Steven signed
in with Google+
on the Android device.
And that takes advantage of the
activities that Google+
has and the interactive posts
that Google+ has too.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah one
feature that I saw, maybe
switching to the mobile app,
is the ability to actually
petition a theater, if it's
not available in your
neighborhood.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah.
Yeah.
So we've been working really
hard-- obviously, Kevin and
Evan driving this van
around the country.
We're trying to get more
theaters every day.
We're in about 200
locations now.
But we're not everywhere.
So what you can do, if your on
our app, you can click Can't
Find Your Theater poster.
Sean's pretty face
will be there.
And then we'll give you
a list of all the
theaters around you.
And you can petition for them.
Basically, what a petition
means is--
I'm going to say and Google+
that I want this theater.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And that's
an interactive post?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Exactly.
Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
And then--
so talking about the mobile
application-- so how did you
guys implement that?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, so
it's a native app.
We use a lot of standard third
party widgets, like the action
bar Sherlock I think is
one of them that's
really cool to use.
The Grids is another thing
that really was
helpful in our layout.
Is there anything else that
you can think of, Steven?
STEVEN NGUYEN: We use some
SDK for RESTful API.
And we are going to use--
I think we are looking
into Volley.
So that comunicates with
your Python back-end.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Exactly.
STEVEN NGUYEN: Yes.
Uh huh.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah.
And then you're using the
YouTube Android player API for
video playback.
What about the video itself,
like how you guys know which
trailer to play?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, it's
a little bit of a manual
process right now.
STEVEN NGUYEN: Old school.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, we're
pretty old school when it
comes to that.
We're not used to grunt work.
So yeah, when we
sign up with--
sorry, when we get showtimes for
a theater, we'll have to
pick the movie out.
And then we'll put in that
YouTube trailer ID.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Got it.
Yeah.
We have to scour YouTube.
Unfortunately, no data
API integrations yet.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah yeah.
For those of you watching, you
can actually do that look-up
using our Data API, so you
can look for trailers.
So I recommend using that.
As you guys grow, it may become
increasingly more
difficult to actually
stay on top of that.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Definitely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then, we
were chatting earlier today
about some of the capabilities
that Data API might give you
the [? VGC ?]
area, like shell-casing, some
user generated content.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah,
I'm pretty
excited by that actually.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So have you guys looked into
the Data API [INAUDIBLE]
yet?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Not yet.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good.
So that's something that maybe
you can do later today.
[LAUGHTER]
And then one question that I
always ask my guests here is
did you guys run into anything
unexpected, like things that
you didn't expect and learned
while developing the
application, whether they
technical issues or business
challenges, like anything you
would be willing to share with
our audience?
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah, I think,
from start to prospective,
trying to figure out the right
product to sell was a
challenge for us in
the beginning.
So two years ago, when Sean
came up with this idea.
It was very much an opaque
model, similar to Hotwire,
where you could pick a movie,
and we'd tell you one of two
occasions where this movie
could be playing.
But users really didn't
like that experience.
And so we changed it
to this opaque
model based on showtime.
And like, OK, we'll play you
this movie at this theater you
want, and it's a really good
discount, it's even better
than if we were to tell you
the exact showtime.
But you'd have to be one
of these random two.
And people didn't like either.
So at the day, it's really down
to getting to know the
exact showtime that you want at
the exact location that you
want it at.
And the deal doesn't have to
be so high but just enough
that you're going to use
Dealflicks to get that deal.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Um hm.
Cool.
So you guys did some changes
to the business
model as you went on.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah.
Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anything on
the API front that you guys
wish we had and we don't?
ZACHARY CANCIO: I think it's
been requested a lot-- but a
native iOS experience
[INAUDIBLE] player.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
that's true.
So right now, you guys have
iOS up right now.
And what are you guys use
there for playback?
ZACHARY CANCIO: We just
use a UIWebView.
STEVEN NGUYEN: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
the I-Frame embed.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That
is something that
actually comes up a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
Cool.
ZACHARY CANCIO: No worries.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So I'm going to see if we have
any questions from our
audience real quick here.
I see there's one question
that is relevant.
And I think it's addressed
to me.
[LAUGHTER]
Is YouTube Developer
Relations hiring?
Yes, we are hiring.
To learn more, go to
developers.google.com/jobs
Well, I think this is it.
Thank you very much
for coming down.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Thanks
for having us
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you for
sharing the super discount
coupon to our audience.
ZACHARY CANCIO: YouTube live.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I'll book
a movie ticket tonight.
ZACHARY CANCIO: Sounds great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And for those
of you watching, thank
you for your time.
And we'll see you again
next week live on
Wednesdays, 10 AM Pacific.
Bye.